some government leaders are sounding the
alarm about how the coronavirus crisis
could eventually stretch hospitals to
their breaking point
your Governor Andrew Cuomo warned
yesterday the country does not have
enough hospital beds to handle a
pandemic and now as Carter Evans shows
us health care workers are voicing their
concerns about shortages of some crucial
medical supplies you have people on
Gurney's in hallways that is what is
going to happen now if we do nothing as
hospitals across the country brace for a
surge in patients some healthcare
workers say medical equipment shortages
are already putting them and their
patients at risk
give us the protections that we need to
give the care that our patients need
bonnie castillo is the executive
director of national nurses united one
of their main concerns a shortage of n95
masks that can filter out 95% of
airborne particles last week the CDC
posted new guidelines saying health care
workers could use the looser fitting
surgical masks as an acceptable
alternative nurses are being asked to
actually reuse masks including surgical
masks which provide no protection the
nonprofit organization direct relief
which helps equip doctors and nurses
manages this massive California
warehouse stocked with essential
supplies including and 95 masks there's
a high risk we could run out with CEO
Thomas tag says they've been contacted
by at least 150 community health centers
lacking supplies after donating nearly 1
million masks to China earlier this year
they have less than half a million left
in stock we could run out of them today
if we've tried to respond to every order
that we have pending the association of
Public Health lab says some of the
chemical ingredients used in coronavirus
tests are in short supply Diagnostics
testing giant hydrogen one of the
companies that makes them says they've
increased production to seven days a
week to keep up with demand
it's spreading much quicker than what we
have seen before so the surge of demand
everywhere in the world and specifically
in the u.s. is quite significant and the
American Red Cross says there's a severe
blood shortage
20700 blood drives have been canceled
resulting in 86 thousand fewer donations
health care workers say the protective
measures taking over the next few weeks
will be critical nurses and doctors are
already getting sick yes that's true and
more will and as more get sick and have
exposure we get sidelined and then who's
there to take care of the patients
for CBS is warning Carter Evans Los
Angeles